this is an individual vericia verigata
ruft lemur uh individuals of this
species i don't think it was the
subspecies but of this species lived on
the island nosy mangaby where just off
the coast of madagascar where i did my
dissertation research
and there this was in the late 90s i was
told by a local man and naturalist that
a particular plant whose identity i've
long since forgotten
was eaten by varicia very god it was
eaten by individual females of this
species of lemur as an abortifacient
now i don't know if this is true i've
never seen i don't see it in the
literature
he assured me and i asked another
naturalist and he said yeah i've heard
that too but i have no idea if that's
one or two data points i don't know from
from once it originally comes
but
the idea that apropos nothing we weren't
talking you know i wasn't talking in my
very poor french in his pretty middling
french neither of us in our first
languages while walking around the
rainforest in madagascar about
reproductive rights you know we just we
ran into a troop with these guys
and he mentioned that there was this
this plant that the females ate
as a way to terminate their pregnancies
when they needed to
um whether or not that particular thing
is true it got me thinking then and has
me thinking again now
about
the fact that it shouldn't surprise us
if this
and other smart animals find ways to
solve their own problems
and
there are a lot of reasons that a woman
or a rough lemur might feel the need to
terminate a pregnancy this issue has
never simply been
as simple as it's a life which is what
we are told which is what you know what
the the sort of the tagline for the
position of the extremists on the right
is it's a life
for some people that is the issue
beginning middle end that's all you have
to say that's all there is to consider
but for most of us
it's it's not there's just more to it
and the fact of there being um
two
organisms involved a pregnant female in
this case of a libra or a
pregnant adult human female in the case
of uh women
uh
doesn't
that and and a fetus
does not acknowledge i mean it does not
it's not responsive the argument that
it's a life is not responsive to
actually what about the other life
you're talking about here
and again i don't know if actually
other organisms are using plants and
supportive patients it wouldn't surprise
me i've been told it's true i can't find
evidence in literature but of course the
organisms aren't going out and putting
stuff into the scientific literature are
they
so
i guess i wanted to add this in a couple
of other little pieces in here about how
really
complex and messy categories are
how simple some of them are
things like
female
very simple
but at the point of
whether or not women should have a right
to terminate a pregnancy that if they
carried it through to term uh would
radically alter everything that they
could do with their own lives and would
likely mean a much poorer quality of
life for that child
uh
to respond to that with it's a life we
can't have this conversation
has always felt like it is missing the
point missing the point and you know i
think your
allusion to
the recent
um debate over
defining
what a woman is for example is exactly
right this throws you and me for a loop
because the answer is well
this is a biological question
right it has a
you know 500 million year history at the
very least
and so
you know the necessary tools to even
have the discussion are not limited to
this moment in history in this
particular species they are embedded in
a much bigger story that has a lot of
logical rungs on the ladder and this one
is the same way right the fact is even
birth
is a bit arbitrary right a human
baby
is not independent even if we say it's
viable because it can survive at this
moment
survive means with the intense care of
adults right and
very few people right a
vanishingly tiny number would be
comfortable in a society that has as
much abundance as we have with people
terminating their already born children
because their economic circumstances
have changed so the point is we already
draw a line in which the point is we say
actually you have to care for this
individual beyond this point or you have
to you know at least make sure that they
are cared for
[Music]